and in many of your films  you know you have  show a great concern with the ecology  and sort of the human impact on the  environment you know it's it's like you  have sort of the natural phenomena  nature playing kind of a greater role in  in your stories  who is it I mean with it has this become  kind of through your career a growing  concern because you've been showing it  now in the numerous films didn't eat and  occasionally dogs are enacted more  kukukaka techno Escarra my talk to uni  motocross moku me forget the great  representative who did not sue me  yeah between bukas moon was good though  you fool me Kodomo tachi book ramen are  does not deal anymore  so reduced are you drunk at you are  inadequate on the rock today  you